[Musique]
manquons de lits pour une raison très
simple c'est que depuis des années nous
contestons la politique du flux tendu à
l'hôpital et du flux tendus pour les
maladies les plus graves sur les malades
qui doivent aller en réanimation le long
d'une animation n'a quasiment pas
augmenté ces vingt dernières années
alors que la population s'est accrue que
elle a vieilli et que les techniques de
réanimation font que l'on prend enfin
des patients qui auparavant ne venaient
pas en réanimation
aucune aucune expérience n'a été tirée
de la période que nous avons vécu depuis
maintenant plus d'un an puisque après la
première vague au mois de mai juin nous
sommes revenus au même nombre de lits
que nous avions avant la crise c'est à
dire en janvier 2020 pour tous le
directeur national 5500 lice à dire à un
tour de lit de réanimation très
inférieur à ce que possède de très
nombreux pays étrangers comparables en
termes de niveau de vie et de
l'organisation du système de santé
de quoi avons nous besoin à ce jour
quelques uns de crise exceptionnelle ce
sont des livres réanimation donc je
porte que qu'en ce moment on manque
peut-être les jambes
alors après deux lits de réanimation
mais ça n'empêche pas que dans la même
structure hospitalière vous avez des
lits actuellement vacants qui sont des
nids d'élite chirurgie risqueront des
programmes des lits de médecine
puisqu'on des programmes également donc
dire que dans l'absolu on manque de vie
pour moi ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens si
je peux me permettre aux morts pour
l'instant d'adaptation de l'hôpital
public à une crise majeure qui est donc
développé momentanément un nombre de
lits de réanimation
suffisant pour accueillir cette crise
donc résonnait déjà sous forme de crise
pour des remords du lit ce n'est pas
tout à fait adéquates
la logique du flux tendu est un non sens
de nombreuses études françaises
internationales montrent comme quand un
hôpital dépasse 80% le taux d'occupation
série ils disent fonctionne et que ces
dysfonctionnements entraîne une
surmortalité une surmortalité pour les
patients classique de 9% les par mes
patients les plus graves de 30%
cerise sur le gâteau la semaine dernière
la cour des comptes
la cour des comptes qui a quand même pas
madame plus validé le fait que nous
manquons depuis des années de l'île
réanimation en france voilà c'est une
des raisons de la crise parce que le
nombre de malades que nous avons
accueillir aujourd'hui n'a rien de des
normes
nous sommes aujourd'hui en réanimation
nouveau les malades qu'ovide environ
4800 4900 patients alors que au pic de
l'épidémie au printemps dernier nous
étions montés à 7500 voilà donc la
réalité c'est que l'hôpital
ces dernières années a subi des coupes
sombres complètement inadapté avec une
logique qui était strictement financière
où il y assure on peut diminuer le
nombre de lits de réanimation le nombre
de lits de chirurgie parce que la
chirurgie ambulatoire permet de réduire
le temps d'hospitalisation des patients
mais la fédération hospitalière de
france qui est quand même la
représentation institutionnelle des
hôpitaux a déclaré l'an dernier par le
biais de son président monsieur madame
tout inquiet maire ancien les
républicains de fontainebleau qui disait
nous pouvons fermer des lits de
chirurgie mais il ne faut pas que ça
soit une suppression nette pour les
transformer en lits de médecine parce
que avec une population qui vieillit
nous avons besoin de plus de lits de
médecine et le moins 10 de chirurgie
voilà donc tous ces éléments valides
notre argumentation le modèle du service
que l'on veut remettre en valeur est
complètement obsolète
il est trop petit pour permettre
justement d ensemble suffisamment vaste
permettant une grande souplesse et
d'adapter en fonction d'une pathologie
du moment il ya dirigiste et
extraordinaire à l'hôpital et on sait
très bien que dans certains services le
chef de fils fait en sorte de réserver
les trois quarts des livres pour ne pas
recevoir des lits de médecine des vides
d'urgence 1
c'est un problème d'organisation au sein
d'un hôpital pour qu'il y ait dans
chacun des disciplines suffisamment de
lits disponibles ou des espaces
disponibles pour recevoir normalement
dignement des patients qui effectivement
est cet honteux un patient de john
pappas et +2 tu dirais 5 heures ce qui
est énorme dans un service d'urgence
donc il ya un problème d'organisation
un problème de souplesse un problème
d'adaptation hors l'hôpital est une
machine bureaucratique rigide
psychorigide organisationnel qui fait
que quand on est difficulté la seule
solution passe et c'est de rajouter
c'est de rajouter dans mon établissement
quel plus grand hôpital d'europe
l'assistance publique-hôpitaux de paris
nous n'avons plus de démissions quels
candidats à l'embauché ont regardé
conditions de travail qui se sont
dégradées et de la faiblesse des
rémunérations dans une grande métropole
comme la région parisienne donc il faut
former du personnel est là pour former
du personnel et écoutez il faut s'en
donner les moyens
est ce qu'on propose aujourd'hui c'est
d'avoir une verte politique
prévisionelle des emplois et de revenir
à ce qu'on faisait quand on avait des
difficultés pour recruter à l'hôpital
dans les années soixante dix et
jusqu'aux années 80 c'est vrai c'est la
politique des contrats c'est à dire que
quand les étudiants sont pas sa
sélection qu'on rentrait dans leur école
professionnelle et bien il ya une pré
embauche ils sont payés pendant leurs
études et ensuite ils sont ils doivent
de 3,5 en sept ans sur la durée de leurs
études à l'hôpital qui a participé au
financement de leurs études
monsieur prix là je suis 100% d'accord
sur tout ce que vous venez dire en
dernière truc il faut un rang d'hôpital
attractif c'est fondamental alors on
peut se poser des questions pourquoi ils
devaient pas le pesanteurs
bureaucratiques vous l'avais dit je suis
100% reçu pour un dégraissage de la
partie technique ou administratif de
l'hôpital des tutelles je vous dirai pas
comme il ya deux salariés à la race dans
une adresse que j'ai connus qui est
passé de 80 à 800 si vous permettez
d'eau il faut rendre il faut travailler
sur l'attractivité de l'hôpital vous
travaillez sur les
10 son travail des personnels soignants
faut travailler sur leurs conditions de
rémunération ont fait rien sans rien
hier modèle s'appelle qui s'appelle le
magnet hospital le monal maniaque
hospital sait comment fait dans
l'hôpital monod réfugiés il y avait des
listes d'attentes pour être embauché
[Musique]